face à la gravité du contexte auquel
nous sommes confrontés face à la
profondeur et à la complexité des défis
qui se présentent à nous je n'ai dans
cette responsabilité nouvelle qu'une
seule et unique aspirations celle de
faire au mieux
sans être jamais garanti quand on essaie
de faire au mieux de bien faire parce
que chacun qui a exercé la
responsabilité du gouvernement
c'est parfaitement la complexité des
choses est que la volonté ne suffit pas
toujours à surmonter tous les défis mais
sans elle rien n'est possible
cette volonté je veux la mettre chaque
jour sur le métier avec une boussole et
une seule c'est la boussole la plus sûre
c'est la boussole la plus fiable
elle porte le nom du sens de l'état je
souhaite le faire de façon absolument
désintéressé puisque je ne suis pas dans
la compétition qui s'engagent mais avec
l'amour de la patrie
l'amour de la france et la volonté de
faire en sorte que notre pays s'élève au
dessus de lui même